the US Justice Department's indictment
money involved in the two-decade-old
bribery scheme passed through Citigroup
and JP Morgan are the banks involved
that is the question for Bloomberg Harry
Geiger who covers the financial industry
and joins us now with more to be clear
Kerry thank you joining us no Bank has
been accused of any wrongdoing but
explain to us what the potential
vulnerability is here it's not sure that
the banks are actually vulnerable it
actually looks like the banks are
providing key pieces of evidence in this
case because of the existence of the
accounts and if you look through the
indictment which I encourage everybody
to do it's a great read for these
officials is it shows very clearly how
much of this bribe money was put into
very specific counts around the world
and a lot of those are JPMorgan accounts
Citigroup accounts wachovia accounts and
so because of that they're US dollars
often that were transferred in these
accounts and their US banks that that
helps bolster the case for the US
Department of just sit that they have
jurisdiction on this case so it's a
great way for them to build up the
evidence we're not right now although
this case is ever-changing and
complicated expecting any blowback on
the banks but it does look like they're
they're offering key pieces of evidence
here what about know your client rules
so my question yes yeah and because
suspicion of corruption is hardly a new
thing at FIFA people have been named in
press reports for years so some of these
banks had a pretty good idea who might
be conducting you know fraudulent you
know might be engaged in fraud and money
laundering or whatever the case might be
right so for a bank if they follow their
own compliance you know programs filing
SARS suspicious activity reports those
are called even on people that are
accused of being corrupt unless it's a
full-blown criminal that's on some type
of watch list they're not really doing
anything wrong I mean they're filing all
their paperwork and so forth you have to
look like these are international
executive executive that are part of
what we now know is a alleged criminal
organization it's not like a Mexican
drug cartel you know but there are
stories about briefcases full of you
know Amidala exactly hotel room right at
some point that suitcase presumably went
to a bank where some alarm presumably
and very very well could have been the
paperwork was filed on that and it's
fine so yes so far it looks like it's ok
but as I said it's unfolding and it's to
be seen all right Kari Geiger thank you
so much